after 13 years in power and some
damaging state election results Angela
Merkel's Authority is visibly waning
she's giving up the leadership of the
Christian Democrats but she'll stay on
as Chancellor my guest this week here in
Berlin is vote Gong shawbly one of
Germany's most famous and infamous
politicians a former finance minister
for the Christian Democrats now
president of the Parliament how long can
a wounded Angela Merkel cling on to
power
[Music]
what gang shortener welcome to comic-con
is this the beginning of the end for
Angela Merkel in politics yes of course
he has announced that she will not run
again for the presidency of the party
and she hasn't known that this means
that she will not run again after this
period which by the way is from 2017 to
2021 can she last that long till 2021
she's wounded not too much I think she
has taken the right decision at the
right time and look the position of an
elected Chancellor in our Constitution
is on behalf of expertise we head with
the failure of the Weimar Constitution
very strong way once elected as
Chancellor you can only be thrown out
against your own desire without your
agreement if SIA is in majority in
parliament who elect another chancellor
say this by the way was also respect not
thinkable not to be imagined in this
given bundle in this given Parliament
therefore a position this constitution
is strong but inside the party she has
her critics and her enemies of course
but the party in choice to have the
federal chancellor as member of the
party and not a member of another party
therefore I think as a party will be
fine vs. thinks maybe she's already
admitted she's lost the trust of the
people she already said that before the
elections so she's on her way down the
only question is how fast she goes down
nobody knows look what's happened this
is it a lot of things which come
together in some way our as we call it
Western system of democracy rule of law
parliamentarism is under stress what
happened in UK UK them
the origin of modern parliamentarism
moved the most important assistant in
for the first decades in this century
for UK from Westminster to a referendum
crazy what's going on
all our continental Europe member states
of the European Union and your
volatility made so stiff look what
happened in France two years ago but the
authority no longer connects to the
voters there were massive losses in HESA
your sister party suffered massive
losses in Bethesda before that you'll no
longer connect you provide them with a
great economy no state wages most
employment no they don't want you
anymore Sparty's all over europe would
be happy you've said would get 27% of
all voters ever but not the ones who got
41% last time it's a huge loss what I am
saying is all I'm trying to say is we
have different reasons one reason is the
tectonic 'el change in modern democracy
I think the main reason for this is a
disruption in communication in
communication which we enjoy by all we
suffer whatever you like by sympathy new
technologies the next problem is linked
resists the globalization to be
influenced by all by development spies
by events in all over the world we have
German people became aware in the
migration crisis in 2015 and then of
course any long period of government
stable government successful government
and not is not to be disputed without
any doubt the chancellorship of angular
magnet has been impressively and
extraordinary successful for a long time
yes but now but now no longer no no
longer no beneficence the beneficiaries
are the far right and
the greens and the AFT there is a normal
way of life everything in human in human
life in human existence is for a time
and her time is over now not over but
your time is coming here Yoshi is
weakened he's not as strong as he used
to be but she is not as big and she has
taken a decision in a very sovereign
matter but for this she's not weakened
otherwise any president let's say in
France let's say in UK in United States
in his second term would be weakened
that is not true but you can't ignore
the fact that she is part of the problem
isn't she now for your party she's no
longer the solution she is part of the
problem in politics you know this better
than I do you either go up or you go
down yeah you don't stay still you don't
stay still that's human life yeah and
she's going down she's going down maybe
but she is strong she'll remain strong
she won't be seen as strong though
she'll be seen as wounded now she's
wounded and she is strong post together
and therefore I would I would not be so
so decided she has announced he will not
run again that is an important step to
announce it I think she is a good chance
and behavior we will be agreeing in my
party that we will not that we will do
what we can to avoid such a separation
of lame-duck
and therefore we would see what will
happen it's not acceptable already
calling her a lame duck that the
succession battle has begun as its of
course it's normal in any in and it's
going to be bloody isn't it after 13
years it will be bloody I think most
most competitors will survive it may not
be so bloody
who are going to be the top candidates
we will see I don't know I will not give
I've been given answer to you it's not
my it's not my role in German politics
to give another and that's question and
this very day to be very frank from your
point of view isn't the worst aspect of
these elections the recently election
that the far-right AFD now has seats in
all 16 regional Parliament's and is the
only other party apart from yours to
have seats in all the regional parts
that's a huge achievement for them
that's the worst aspect for you isn't it
some relative strengths of the
right-wing party AFD is of course I
agree so the worst thing and it's a vast
aspect for my for my perspective but
it's a matter of fact we have a FG
mattress around about 9 I think 92
members of parliament in the federal
parliament they are all electors they
have all equal rights and equal to T's
now as I show in all state Parliament's
by the way we have seen in in the last
two state elections in Bavaria as well
as in essence that what has been
foreseen by many observers that they
will move towards 20% or more it's not
decided and it can be changed but of
course what we what we suffer all over
Europe look what happened in France
since decades look what was the very
reason for the proxy referendum in UK if
I remember about that let's say if we
know it's a chest we live with Germany
has been unique your policies your
party's policies opened the door for the
AFD the polls show that 69 percent of
Germans voted AFD because of concerns
immigration I don't agree I would tell
you we have four for nearly six say 65
years in Germany was most time we hit on
behalf of our very specific and rhetoric
past advantage said we didn't have a
relevant right-wing party
in continental to all parts of Europe
the what's going on in Sweden in Finland
in Netherlands of Italy wherever you
like now 70 years 70 years after after
the creation of the Federal Republic of
Germany
it seems set in this regard we also
become move towards them something like
an european normality i don't like it i
don't like it but it's a matter of fact
that immigration gave them the foothold
didn't it your party's immigration if
you look at the policies allowed them to
press the fire button yeah in the
beginning it was it was not immigration
it was the european integration which
was Sabaton to create this party
appalled another cologne Institute of
Economic Research people are united by a
general sense of unease about the future
of their country 69% lament the negative
consequences of immigration that's what
unites the if you ask the voters of
Esmond yesterday what was the most
Austin problems for their decision
immigration is not in the not in the in
the head of the officer range but in the
end they got into the Parliament they've
got 12 percent did all of you as a
European canvass of course my
underestimated the AF they don't
underestimate please did on those no no
we don't you referred to them in 2016 as
boneheads they're not boneheads are they
they're doing much better than boneheads
do we we can dismiss them it is not
decided we can it should be it can't be
changed but it's a matter of fact and of
course we so my Croatian crisis in 2015
create a lot of nervously by the way it
was also for many for many people all
over the world it was a huge achievement
that Germany was seen as
such an open generous tolerant
population and the peoples have been to
migrants have been created
welcome how hard with business in a very
cordial way but look at the backlash
from this backlash as far as the FT look
in 22 European states now you have a
higher concentration of far-right
parties than at any time for the last 30
years maybe but I mean you said last
year I think we can say there's no
chance Germany will ever relapse
internationalism I am quite sure I think
they have we will let's let's let's be
clear they got about 13 percent that
means 87 percent are totally clear I
think many many people in Europe many
state in Europe member states of the
European Union would be happy if the
right-wing party would limit it to
itself
13 percent 5 years ago this was
unthinkable that they would have 90 odd
seats in the Bundestag and be
represented in 1606 emergency maybe in
five years that was unthinkable maybe in
five year I can't remember you said it
would be an and you would say it is
unthinkable that there will be
diminished we will see future is always
open it is but in the light of how well
they've done don't you want to reassess
your come comforting statement that
there's no chance Germany will ever
relapse internationally Germany will
ever never ever relapse into
internationalism but if the broad
majority of German people will never
move towards nationalism you suggest
that European integration was the reason
or part of the reason that the continent
overcame the disaster of Hitler and the
Cold War divisions but there is now what
President macron calls a civil war
taking place in the EU divisions our
values are like a European civil war he
said that in April
the battle between liberal and illiberal
democracies do you take that series no I
don't agree I like the president
nuts and he make him impressive attempts
to get reforms in France done he's very
engaged in poor European Swensen Europe
my cream helpings at this I would not I
would not share this rotting in saying
we are in a city boy and and on Bella's
and thought challenged by the moment
wait a moment I am quite careful in
always crediting our Eastern neighbours
they have a different history they have
different developments I have different
chances and what's I don't need and
what's I don't deserve this
they say are always treated not on an
equal level but say always so I thought
was a feeling that we from the Western
we want to teach them we want to do no
say we didn't have we wouldn't have
German reunification but the club the
important here has rules doesn't yes you
are so keen on countries observe play as
a British you must must be careful to
ask me and on the rules of civil sick
lap of the European because I will tell
you so without the engagement and that
and the courage of East European people
in times of communist and Soviet empire
we wouldn't have in we wouldn't have
enjoyed the German reunification it was
opponent it was check it was Hungary all
these candles and therefore we must be a
little bit more generous to these
countries of course we are doing in the
opposite direction you can be generous
all you want the moving avoidance Victor
wait until rather than a direct
challenge hasn't he said Brussels is
currently ruled by those who want a
European Empire no directed more voters
voice sayings it said art yeah there's a
lot of bureaucrats my gracious
politicians won't you make me you make
me impatient bees also respect quoting
that's what he wants no wait a moment
and that's all so fast me too
okay so let's be quiet to quote some
political leaders with some specific
words makes no sense in public this in
in discussion in substance we are
breaking for common rules in Europe by
the way you have seen Poland I take poll
is an example say have a different
understanding on the reform of the
justice system but when the European
Court decided last week they have to
cancels I have to to correct yet it's a
decision to send say a lot of chances to
the in pension they corrected it to
entire and the other pensions the
pensioners has hello justice has been
called back safer as long as the
decisions of the European Court are
respected by member states I would not
criticize him I'm a lawyer and then law
lawyer knows there are always different
opinions at the end I should never let
me talk to you as a lawyer because the
subject of rules came up and you have
been most insistent when talking about
them in 2016 you said it clearly all
nations must stick to the rules of the
single currency yes was my bosses don't
they don't who doesn't the stability
pact was introduced since it's been
introduced not a single year has gone by
without at least one member country's
finances breaching --use guidelines you
know this you know this no but who are
the rules for the little countries no we
in Germany we to be try to respect the
rules really in my in my time in my time
as finance minister I did work to for
for a respect exude I have to I know he
has 76 rule infringement cases against
you now in in the Brussels to the Greens
you are no longer a model pupil your
bottom up obvious Japanese bottom of the
class yeah we are not we are not
immortal we have never understood our
service immortal for others cities that
is not brought but what we do why don't
you obey the rules what we do everyone
we do respect this if the European Court
decides we respect the decision
therefore the rule of law is very
important and and and we do respect of
course I don't say that Germany is
without any mistake by far not but what
I what I am asking for they said we have
mutual respect and we don't always blame
our neighbors in the East I don't like
it but you've always said play by the
rules and since 2011 Germany has
continuously been in breach of European
current account I just has to behave
just have defended its impression of
arrogance in relation to our East
Eastern European neighbors now you are
blaming Germany hypocrisy isn't that
from Germany on this what the focus is
telling people to obey the rules and you
don't no one is perfect even German is
not perfect you can see I always clear
that I am working in my country to do
respects the rules but we that we don't
we are not better sense of Polish and as
a member says that respecting see roots
is an ongoing petal of every day and
before you criticize others you have
always to care on yourself and we have a
lot of reasons to care ourselves but
having said this I would not say
ceremony does not respect the rules in
my time as finance minister
I was not criticized not all respects
the rules for finance the finance ocean
and even the pact on stability and
growth and now sharply you have Italy
the latest challenge to eurozone rules
you're smiling about this but they've
thrown down a severe challenge to
Brussels haven't they and jean-claude
Juncker says it once again threatens the
euros existence first time first time
that Italy's budget has been turned down
but I would I smiled because I would
have enjoyed if all his people he who
are now saying this in relation to Italy
would have supported me in the times
when we tried to tell the Greek people
let's say have to respect the rules
there's also respect there for every
session was that you went too far with
Greece education in my Parliament has
been I have been too generous in
relation to grace and that was also true
because the quiz didn't respect the
rules but having said this we did it in
in in a suitable way and I will tell you
I was happy that the European Commission
has set rules our rules I quote PMS
QVC's a responsible Commission member of
Commission and he said holds our rules
and I was happy because in former times
he criticized me in saying that rules
have to be respected now but the problem
with Italy is that the iteration is
telling them they can't have their
budget do you really think that Brussels
can tell a freely elected country whose
economy has been stagnant for the best
part of 20 years that it can't pursue
the policies it was elected to implement
you really think that's wait wait a
moment wait a moment you just tried to
convince me that we should respect the
rules now you are telling me we should
not ask to Italy to stick the walls okay
maybe it's a contradiction but having
said this I both sides I see I just want
you to play one I ever tell you I play
my was the same I am totally convinced
it's a problem of Italy is not a lack of
death of a lack of deficit that is not
the problem of Italy if a lack of tests
that means increasing this increasing
deficit would solve Italian problems
that's wrong say how serious the crisis
is this is serious but I think but I
think markets will tell them you will
not get financed do if you if you have
huge deficit and you want to increase
your huge deficit you always have to
find someone who is if your credit you
have to pay a price and you see you can
see the spreads are increasing the rates
are increasing therefore I hope this
presentation is serious
you Commission is doing the right job in
this when the Italians have said we are
not giving in
yeah not good Spidey let's wait and see
let's wait and if they don't give it and
there's no resolver see we will see I
will not speculate but we were saved I
want to be on it I don't like to people
play a big male never like to be black
metaphor what's related reads I want if
I made to talk briefly about Saudi
Arabia and Germany's decision to suspend
arms sales to Riyadh after the murder of
the journalist Jamal khashoggi excuse me
I am NOT member of government I am
president of the Bundestag Federal
Parliament I do this appropriate ice
tourists like myself to commend any
decision of politicians and government
in this very time having said this I
would like to make clear Chancellor
Merkel has said if I quote rightly until
this affair is cleared and here we know
what's happened we will suspend he did
not say we will cancel all our exposures
at be to suspend until we have a clear
said things have been cleared what
happened and it's offset is to the
government I think it's right I told
sight on what grounds moral grounds it's
right to make pressure sets there must
be a weed we do not we do we have to
know what happened really and why and
who is responsible for this it's a bit
late for morality isn't it I mean there
are morality the Saudis have been
committing war crimes in Yemen
yes ever since that started and your
government did nothing about ok if you
if you want to to church well politics
only or moral moral courage categories
you will always have a lot of problems
you have always find so right parents
you knows if it's a film it's a famous
German scientist Max Weber
hundred years ago said earlier that you
have to decide you have to find the
right balance between what we know and
ethics and responsibility and and to
find the right balance is it is a very
difficult thing every day in politics
you have always thought for the right
balance you must not pursue a politics
without more all right but you can only
you can't on the other hand not replace
politics political decisions only by
models it will not be succeed all right
thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]